bonsoir alexis le chef d'état qui se
veut avancer 1 sur son projet de réforme
des retraites avant la fin de ce
quinquennat mais mais visiblement les
conditions ne sont pas réunies re
et oui on voit bien que emmanuel macron
voudrait aller encore plus vite pour
cette réforme des retraites continue et
c'est bien sur la feuille de route de la
commission européenne pour les milliards
débloqués milliards de dettes un des
deux co vide il doit faire des réformes
structurelles entendez la réforme de
l'allocution de l'allocation chômage et
la réforme des retraites donc emmanuel
macron veut y aller veut faire aussi
preuve de
réformisme puisqu'il a été élu pour ça
et qu'il a été empêché par cette crise
sanitaire avant l'élection évidemment de
2022 ce serait dommage de ne pas montrer
qu'il est ce président réformateur qu'il
prétend vouloir être donc il veut
remettre ça sur la table mais évidemment
tous les partenaires sociaux étaient
contre avant la crise du coc vide
edouard philippe était alors premier
ministre à la place de jean castex il
voulait passer par la force le 49 3 et
moulin de maquereaux envisage également
les décrets or on le voit aujourd'hui
les syndicats sont contre le patronat
commence un peu à voir que le temps
presse alors pourquoi pas mais une
inquiétude demeure quand j'entends
monsieur castex dire qu'il y aura un
comité d'évaluation pour voir l'impact
de ces réformes de la retraite
regardez tous les comités d'évaluation
qui ont existé par le passé où sont
passés par exemple le comité citoyen qui
étaient là pour donner son avis sur la
vaccination envolée évaporés dans dans
l'air donc on peut penser que le comité
d'évaluation pour les retraites sera à
peu près du même acabit l'idée c'est
d'aller vite de continuer la casse
sociale imposée par la politique
progressiste comme il aime à l'appeler
emmanuel macron et et bien sûr demandé
par la commission européenne mais on
voit bien que les conditions ne sont pas
réunies évidemment crise sanitaire d'un
côté crise économique de l'autre on est
loin d'une vraie reprise économique on
est loin encore d'avoir endiguer
complètement ce virus donc il sait de
l'attentisme évidemment c'est de l'
effet d'annonce avec le risque encore
une fois de braquer davantage une
population française déjà fracturé et
déjà fatigués de quatre ans de mandat d'
emmanuel macron alexis en revanche les
conditions sont bel et bien réunis pour
la réforme de l'assurance chômage très
décrié a notamment parlé et syndicats
qui est selon jean castex absolument
indispensable elle sera bien appliquée à
partir du 1er octobre celle ci
oui là encore on voit bien là la
radicalité idéologique de ce
gouvernement qui veut aller vite dans
ses réformes structurelles promises à
l'union européenne donc il va falloir
accélérer la précarisation de ceux qui
sont déjà dans la précarité l'idée étant
que quand on est au chômage hall l'est
par choix c'est faux on l'est par défaut
parce qu'il est difficile de trouver un
travail dans ses champs de compétence
alors il ya bien sûr le pack de
formation continue mais ça ne suffit pas
quand on regarde le nombre d'offres
d'emploi et le nombre de demandeurs le
delta excusez moi c'est pas le variant
delta mais la différence est énorme et
donc on ne voit pas comment ce chômage
de masse pourrait disparaître du jour au
lendemain parce que les allocations
chômage vont diminuer donc encore une
fois la pauvreté est un choix politique
c'est c'était celle du gouvernement
thatcher de la politique du guichet du
gouvernement également schröder en
allemagne avec les lois ars qui ont mis
en place cette difficulté pour les
chômeurs d'être indemnisés alors que
rappelons le le chômage n'est pas un
cadeau les travailleurs cotisent tout le
long de leur vie de travail pour ce
moment où ils n'ont pas de travail ce
n'est pas un dû ce n'est pas un cadeau
c'est quelque chose qui coûte aux
travailleurs et aux employeurs et là on
voit bien que la logique derrière c'est
de dire eh bien débrouillé vous après
tout la start up nation c'est l'ubs et
risation et c'est encore moins de droits
sociaux encore moins de tapis sociale or
c'est cette république sociale qui a
permis la france de survoler la crise de
2008 qui a impacté la grèce et d'autres
pays beaucoup plus sévèrement qui a
permis aussi à la france de sortir ces
milliards 1 pour aider les secteurs
comme la restauration et continuer
encore aujourd'hui même si le quoi qu'il
en coûte prend fin et c'est cette force
là finalement qu'on va mettre à la
poubelle tout simplement par idéologie
pour s'aligner encore une fois sur les
partenaires européens sans réfléchir de
ce qu'il sera par la suite si une crise
encore plus grave qu'elle soit
économique systémique bancaire ou autre
arrivait à toucher l'europe et la france
et malgré cet exercice également une
communication alexis qui sont ce
séminaire gouvernemental et plus tard
évidemment cette université d'été début
octobre de la république en marche il y
a tout de même sondage important alors
on s'en méfie parfois mais tout de même
un président juge est loin des français
dans une majorité ne souhaite pas
finalement qu'il se représente
oui c'est un sondage qui a été publiée
par libération alors je ne sais plus
quel et l'institut qui qu'il a réalisés
mais on voit que c'est à peu près 60% de
français qui ne souhaite pas qu'ils
menaient le maquereau se représente avec
une majorité écrasante de français là on
est 70 80 % qui juge emmanuel macron
loin de leur quotidien
décalé des finalement d'un coupé des
français ça c'est pas nouveau il a ce
sobriquet de président des riches on
voit qu'il est vraiment loin évidemment
du quotidien des français dans sa
pratique du pouvoir il aime plutôt
rencontrer les patrons de fonds
d'investissement comme blackrock à
versailles de temps en temps il va dans
des villes comme marseille mais là on
voit bien que les villes sont barricadés
et puis après cdd mise en scène qu'on a
vu pendant trois jours pour montrer
qu'il est un président populaire mais
même cet été il n'a pas fait le
traditionnel bain de foule à brégançon à
qui il faisait chaque année c'est vous
dire comme le divorce est complet entre
la population française et ce président
qui est en voie finalement de hollande
isation un françois hollande qui à la
fin de son mandat était également
totalement mal aimé des français ne
voulaient pas le voir se représentait
d'ailleurs il avait fait le choix de ne
pas se présenter mais aimerait macro est
très différent il aime la confrontation
il aime la violence il sera prêt je
pense à se présenter contre l'avis de
tous sachant qu'il peut être aidé par
les sondages on en parle est incertain
sondages peuvent être biaisées ou
arrondir son image alors qu'il va
proposer des réformes sociales
difficiles dur est encore plus
d'inégalités à la suite de ces réformes
donc il peut compter sur ce type de
communication c'est d'ailleurs ce que
fait la république en marche avec
richard ferrand hier à angers pour la
rentrée parlementaire des macros nist
qui disait que emmanuel macron est le
candidat unique du 21e siècle c'est le
seul candidat de la modernité politique
on en est là c'est quasiment du mao dans
le texte donc pourquoi pas si les
maquereaux nice pense que 50 plus pour
un candidat unique le seul et l'unique
je crois que les français quand on voit
ce sondage attendent autre chose de
l'offre politique et du débat pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22 merci beaucoup
alexis poulain en direct sur rt france